come to the line and its first down
to his left and he hauls it in good
piece of tackling
when your quarterback throwing against
zone defenses look for the open space
that's what he did that time he found it
and the receiver ran in there and maybe
catch 2nd and for Gore middle toggle is
going to make the tackle
to create money back to have on your
football team in d he goes up in there
it gets the first down now you're off
fence has three more chances
now first intent Kaepernick able to fake
in the line it still has it no one in
sight has the graph
captain Excel displayed big time the
defense they go for the run fake and
that's why he has time to throw the
football and makes the completion good
job
that long game sets them up here on this
play
first down here
let's see how they packed up the big
play here Wars taking the handoff
or is brought down hey this defense they
are tough you run in football they got
some men up front and end time they stop
that run just for a short gain Colin
Kaepernick under center with drop back
and there is no
his tackle beyond
it's a first down
good job gives her first gown by the
offense a look at the defensive players
on the sidelines here near teammates on
keep us on the sideline a little longer
that's what they're hoping for the 49ers
front of the 37 Nick's
two
after the two yard carry it sets up
second down and eight
oh and good catch right on the sideline
that's a good job that time on the
quarterback kitty temp pass completion
game now makes third down very
manageable for you on the way third down
offense lines up here just a quick drop
back
gets it to Vernon Davis
the chains
when you keep chipping away with these
short grunts sooner or later that
defense is going to come up and when
they come up that's when you throw it
over the top
the 49ers happen at the 24 and the give
to Frank Gore
nice job that job by the defense table
ready for the run nowhere for the
running back to go one get a stopping
for a short gain second down
colin kaepernick under center
jan forces the end completion when you
see this cover to defense as a
quarterback we've got to know where to
throw the football that time he did not
make a good decision you gotta throw it
sometimes deep down the middle the
safeties are not there they're outside
he did not take advantage of that covers
head time third down and ten
you